but this is an absolutely gigantic
development in the Trump Russia scandal
increasingly we've been looking at
Donald Trump's intent to build a Trump
Tower in Moscow everybody has had a
different story about how serious this
project ever was but more importantly
there have been a lot of denials about
how involved if at all Donald Trump was
we've heard months of denials in fact
denials that said Trump wasn't even
aware of the project being discussed
during the 2016 presidential campaign
months of denials that there are any
signed documents that that there's
anything more than the idea of Michael
Cohen sending a few emails about maybe
some day there could be a Trump Tower
Moscow built and that if there were any
such documents Donald Trump's name
definitely isn't on any of them Donald
Trump's signature more importantly more
accurately isn't on any of them it was
Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen who was
working on this or it was Ivanka and
Eric and Don Jr in any case Donald Trump
was totally out of this deal and not at
all involved except that we now have the
smoking gun that proves that Donald
Trump and his lawyer Rudy Giuliani and
all of them have been lying cNN has
obtained a letter of intent to build
Trump Tower Moscow signed by Donald
Trump with that stereotypical that
trademark huge sharpie signature of
Donald Trump's that we've talked about
before as a reminder before we play the
clip on Sunday just this past Sunday
Donald Trump's attorney Rudy Giuliani
said there is a document but Donald
Trump never signed the document a
document was drawn up never signed by
anybody
never mind by Donald Trump Giuliani
saying to Danna bash on CNN it was a
real estate project there was a letter
of intent to go forward but no one
signed it but then CNN found the letter
and it has been signed and it was signed
by Donald Trump himself take a look take
a look at this this is the letter of
intent
for the proposed Trump Tower Moscow all
right it is signed by Donald J Trump how
do I know well because we've been told
it was by his lawyer and it is and I'll
show it to you in a second now I want
you to take a walk down memory lane to
remind you of what the President himself
has said about this project first he
said there was no deal listen to this I
have nothing to do with Putin I have
nothing to do with Russia I have nothing
to do with Russia we had nothing to do
with Russia you know for a deal that
didn't mean anything it's a lot of pages
man with a lot of detail about what they
wanted and how they wanted it and how
would he be paid and there's a signature
okay there it is that distinctive thick
sharpie signature and once again Rudolph
the Red Nosed lawyer told another lie
and what we now have is confirmation
that Donald Trump signed this recall
that Trump knew the deal involved the
Kremlin because Michael Cohen told him
that it did we have proof in writing Pat
that Donald Trump was doing business
with active adversaries of the United
States while pushing the most Pro Russia
anti Ukraine policy in a long time while
lying about it as he simultaneously ran
for president of the United States well
we can definitely call this a smoking
gun because it's clear-cut evidence you
can see the guy's signature on the
document after all that's as clear as it
gets but it doesn't go to any legal
culpability it just goes to show that
they were lying all along and now
they've been caught in the lie so that's
the significance of this I've said
before and I will say it again there's a
very good chance that this all does not
get Donald Trump removed from office it
should but it will likely not and that's
an indictment of our political system it
should be difficult to remove a
president it should because you don't
want presidents to be able to be removed
merely for political disagreements or
political ganging up on so to speak but
if there are no repercussions for
effectively negotiating away
foreign-policy with real estate deals
promises to Vladimir Putin of penthouse
condos then the United States is simply
not serious about the rule of law and of
democracy and we are just selling to the
highest bidder
which in many ways we've been doing for
decades that that's actually the reality
when will the Republicans come around
and say no more
this has to end this is not about
politics anymore this is about the
sovereignty of the United States where
are they going to get the testicular
fortitude wink wink
to do that when they're often just
scared of Donald Trump and the effect
that their reelection chances may suffer
as a result of coming out and saying it
will they ever
unfortunately Pat is probably right that
they won't but every aspect of every
single one of these stories the Trump
Tower meeting Trump Tower Moscow I could
list them for an hour we are being lied
to constantly and as yet there have been
no repercussions for the big players who
have been telling the lies send me your
thoughts as to their whether there ever
will be such repercussions I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show so yet
another advertiser is bailing out on Fox
News and specifically on Tucker
Carlson's program on Fox News because of
another one of these racially tinged
rants by Tucker Carlson so this is part
of a bigger backstory which is that
advertisers have been bailing on Fox
News and large numbers a ton of them
left Laura Ingram's program after a
number of sort of ethno nationalist
rants on her program Bill O'Reilly
barely had any advertisers left when his
show ended and he was forced out of the
network and it's getting worse and worse
and this is all related to a segment
that Tucker Carlson did last week about
immigration supposedly making the united
states dirtier which is of course
playing on known racists imagery and
stereotypes about immigrants coming to
the United States let's take a look at
just this I could play minutes of it for
you let's just look at like 45 seconds
of it people debate all the time about
mass immigration what you never hear
anybody do is make the economic case for
mass immigration and here's why our
country's economy is becoming more
automated and tech centered by the day
it's obvious that we need more
scientists and skilled engineers with
this now what we're getting instead
we're getting waves of people with high
school education or less nice people no
one doubts that but as an economic
matter this is insane it's indefensible
so nobody even tries to defend it
instead our leaders demand that you shut
up and accept this we have a moral
obligation to admit the world's poor
they tell us even if it makes our own
country poorer and dirtier and more
divided immigration is a form of
atonement yeah so Pacific Life was not
pleased with this and they are the
latest advertiser to bail on Fox News
they were only advertising with Tucker
and they're gone putting out a statement
to The Hollywood Reporter that says
Pacific life's national advertising
campaign runs on numerous networks and
cable stations and on a variety of news
business and sports programs one of our
ads appeared on Tucker Carlson's show
last night following a segment where mr.
Carlson made a number of statements
regarding immigration as a company we
strongly disagree with mr. Carlson's
statements our customer base and our
workforce reflect the diversity of our
great nation something we take great
pride in we will not be advertising on
mr. Carlson's show in the coming weeks
as we reevaluate our relationship with
his program now that could mean one of
two things that really one is they're
canceling altogether but now they're
just saying it's a revaluation and
they'll never come back and hopefully
nobody who likes Fox will notice the
other side would be they're going to
quote reevaluate for a couple of weeks
and then without making any public
statement they will restart advertising
on Fox News if indeed it was profitable
for them to do so also hopefully without
people noticing I don't know which is
going to happen but in general the
advertisers that have bailed
for these reasons have not come back to
Fox News Fox News is writing it off as
liberal activists saying it is a shame
this is a quote it is a shame that
left-wing advocacy groups under the
guise of being supposed media watchdogs
weaponized social media against
companies in an effort to stifle free
speech
Tucker speech isn't stifled it might not
be as profitable for Fox News to have
Tucker Carlson's speech there he can say
whatever he wants though his boss Fox
News may be okay with what he's saying
no one's free speech rights are being
violated in any way but nobody can be
forced to advertise with Fox News or
with Tucker Carlson no matter what the
programming content is right this
doesn't even make me angry because I'm
so used to this stuff from Fox News's
primetime lineup Hannity does it and
Laura Ingraham does it and Tucker does
it they say horrible things
advertisers pull out and they call them
attacks on free speech the right-wingers
claim that this is an issue of
suppression of speech but it's not in
any way shape or form
freedom of speech doesn't mean freedom
from the consequences of that speech and
in this particular case Pat Fox News can
hire whoever it wants to do shows those
people can say whatever they want
assuming their boss is okay with it and
viewers can make a choice as to whether
to watch or not to watch advertisers can
make a choice about whether to advertise
or not to advertise everybody's doing
whatever they want that's Liberty
yeah there's no argument to be made when
it comes to the free speech front going
back the beginning of the year when
Laura Ingraham made those comments about
David Hogg the Parkland survivor and
calling out his grades through his SAT
scores
there was a advertiser boycott that
followed in even among members of our
audience there was kind of a split like
should these companies be doing this and
that was totally their decision to make
but I think in that instance you could
kind of excuse what she said or at least
try to make that argument because it was
a tweet and it wasn't all that offensive
whereas what Tucker Carlson is saying
here is really emblematic of who he is I
mean saying that the country is getting
dirtier that goes this idea of the
Browning of America that we're getting
with immigration and I think it's a
totally does disgusting comment and
excusable I think he's more advertising
of an advertiser boycott than or
Ingraham ever was yeah well at least
maybe because of the the tweet about
David hog although she's since then done
that are basically almost identical to
this latest a teller calls Carlson one
but I think you bring up an interesting
point which is that us being associated
with a host because of their activities
outside of the program on which you're
advertising there is one layer of
separation there whereas now we're
talking about just literally what
happened on the program itself hopefully
this keeps happening although it's not
that clear that Fox is in trouble
because they don't really need to make
money
they are bankrolled they're more like
state media in a sense they have a
profit incentive because it's a
for-profit company they don't actually
have a profit need in the same way that
other for-profit media do because they
are so tied in with the Republican Party
as effectively establishment state media
that they have backers they have
programs that don't even need to be
profitable at all because of the
messaging that their backers want to
have out there and the next year is
going to be very interesting because
it's the Trump crime stories grow which
side will Fox be on if Republicans start
to split on Donald Trump's crimes we
have been seeing slightly more
journalistic rigor when it comes to how
the White House press corps has been
dealing with press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders over the last maybe
three to four weeks one example of this
we talked about a couple of weeks ago
which was CNN deciding to live
fact-check Sarah Huckabee Sanders during
her press briefing so as she started
telling lies
facts would come up on screen in text
form on CNN during a recent White House
press briefing that was a really great
thing we applauded that and that that's
exactly what media outlets should be
doing but I've also insisted that the
press corps really should be doing much
more and that the press corps needs to
step it up when they are in the room
with Sarah Huckabee Sanders including
when she doesn't answer a question and
moves on to the next reporter the next
reporter to be called on instead of
asking their question should insist hey
hold on a second Sarah you didn't answer
that last question I have the same
question let's see if you can answer it
now that it's been asked a second time
call her out make her either
answer the question
or cut the press-conference short which
is probably what she would do we are now
seeing basically the approach of doing
both of those things from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders a couple of days ago Sarah
Huckabee Sanders showed up to the White
House press briefing room an hour late
without any explanation constantly cut
off answers and kept talking about being
short on time and then cut the entire
thing short after about five minutes and
fortunately some of the reporters in the
room called her out and said Sarah why
don't you do your job I'm gonna play a
little bit of audio and video for you
here listen for someone in the room who
goes oh when another reporter says Sarah
do your job this is what press briefings
have become in this administration I
encourage you guys to tune of the
president's event it was a ten-minute
briefing do your job Sarah what an
absolute and utter embarrassment she was
asked about Trump's charity being forced
to shut down over rampant criminality
she was asked about Donald Trump's
threat to shut down the government that
he issued when he was at the Oval Office
at that wacky meeting with Democratic
leadership Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer she dodged answering every
single question and then left after
somewhere between five and ten minutes
why even bother doing this Pat right I
mean it would almost attract less
attention to stop doing the briefings
altogether than to do them in this way
well I think Sarah Huckabee Sanders has
one foot out the door
remember that report from the beginning
of the year saying that Sarah would be
leaving the administration come around
this time I think that's what's going on
I think she's ready to go the press she
may be going and the press briefings
actually may stop altogether NPR has an
interesting article which points out
that if you look at the frequency of
these briefings and the duration of the
briefings both are declining and I was
reminded of that movie
from the 90s with Will Smith
Independence Day where there's a signal
coming from the alien spacecraft which
is dwindling and they can calculate that
if it continues at this pace the signal
will end altogether and at that point of
course the aliens will attack it's sort
of the same thing if you follow the
signal of duration shrinking and
frequency being reduced by sarah
huckabee sanders for her press briefings
the press briefing will disappear in
something like six months the press
briefing for the time being is down to
something like every couple of weeks
five to ten minutes because there's
really no way to spend more than five or
ten minutes in front of the press corps
without being exposed for the totally
embarrassing actions of the president
that she is trying to cover up and
explain every single day amazing time to
live amazing time to be living through
and III just can't even imagine what
we're going to see in 2019 send me your
thoughts should they just stop the press
briefings altogether I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show i was thinking over the
weekend how things have really changed
in the last year in American politics in
so many ways not only the perception of
the United States around the world and
not only sort of role of the US in
really important discussions about the
climate and about authoritarianism and
fresh press freedoms and free press and
so many other areas but also how much
things have changed in terms of the
President of the United States and what
I mean by that is that a year ago we had
the Trump Russia investigation in this
sort of earlier phase we had a sort of
obviously bogus House Intelligence
Committee investigation which we knew
was never going to find anything it was
after all led by Donald Trump's friend
Devin Nunez who was running to the White
House to keep Trump apprised of what it
was that that committee was doing now as
we are almost at the end of 2018 we're
learning that almost every aspect of the
president's life before being candidate
Trump during the campaign during the
presidency every aspect of Donald
Trump's life may contain criminality and
it is the presidency
which has exposed that and now he and
his family and his inner circle are all
under investigation for possible
criminality remember that before being
handed at Trump we now have learned that
Donald Trump may have been involved in
the money laundering of Russian and
Saudi money through real estate deals
particularly in Manhattan New York
Donald Trump was employing undocumented
immigrants both by proxy through the
undocumented immigrants employed by
contractors that Donald Trump worked
with and also even directly we've now
learned that multiple undocumented
immigrants were working at Donald
Trump's New Jersey Golf Club at minimum
that we know of
specifically shady banking deals with
Deutsche Bank under very strange
circumstances that robert muller is
looking into those are examples of
possible criminality by Trump before he
even decided to run for president of the
United States then we get to the
campaign where there is a whole slew of
additional possible criminality illegal
coordination with Russia receiving
things of value from foreign countries
for the purposes of winning an election
in his case the 2016 presidential
election directing felonious payoffs via
his attorney Michael Cohen to mistresses
possibly in conjunction with ami the
parent company of the National Enquirer
and many others and then we also get to
phase three which is during the
presidency and even transitioning in the
to the presidency potential crimes now
around fraud regarding Donald Trump's
inauguration and donations that were
received for it that is now being
investigated of course we've been
talking for months now obstruction of
justice of the Trump Russia probe firing
all sorts of people including James
Comey witness tampering
both implicitly and explicitly via
private and public means trying to
influence the testimony of individuals
within the context of that investigation
emoluments violations dignitaries from
around the world choosing to stay at
Donald Trump's hotel in Washington DC to
ingratiate themselves with him of course
funneling money directly to his
personal pocket since that is one of his
businesses and you know what Pat it's
not even just Trump so we've got
possible Trump criminality before during
and after he was candidate Trump we also
now have Trump's family
increasingly pulled into this Donald
Trump jr. expecting an indictment
considering heading to Canada so that
he's gone when the news breaks his
business associates others from the
Trump Organization his advisers and
attorneys cabinet members are dropping
like fry flies interior secretary Ryan
Zinke is bailing under a huge black
cloud of misuse of taxpayer money as
usual ten cabinet secretaries in total
have now left more than Obama and Bush
and Clinton lost in two years sixty
percent of trumps aides have left in the
first two years outrageous turnover rate
more than the last five presidents by
far so this is now pat every aspect of
Donald Trump's life even now possible
criminality on the behalf of Donald
Trump's father has come to light not
that that would be prosecutable the guy
died long ago this is not the best
decision for Trump has it been to become
President of the United States not a
good decision at all and I don't know if
they would take it back if he could and
many of these possible crimes we knew
about before he was even elected
president that's why we thought there
was something shady with the fact that
he wouldn't release his tax returns we
knew there was some sketchy ties between
him and the Saudi Arabians or him and
the Russians and you can't also forget
the serial sexual assault and harassment
of women many of those cases I'm sure
border on criminality so this was all
kind of baked in and the American public
knew about this before voting for him
that's why I'm kind of concerned that if
something major comes out that it won't
change things because this has already
baked into the cake and you have now
legal experts even one on Fox News
saying that Donald Trump is effectively
an unindicted co-conspirator in at least
the crimes of Michael Cohen because he
directed Michael Cohen to commit those
felonies the only element of this that's
out of place is that the devoted
trumpets and the devoted right-wing
media
tend that this is not happening if we
can say anything positive about Donald
Trump it's that very few people of his
profile would actually survive this
onslaught he shouldn't be able to
survive this given the rampant
criminality that's been exposed but he
might because of a combination of the
power of the Oval Office and incumbency
and the fact that he still has committed
ideological hardcore right-wing media
allies that are pretending that nothing
is going on because this should have
destroyed him a long time ago and it
still might we don't know just yet and
part of it of course is that there are
two justice systems I've been talking
about this for years we have a justice
system for the wealthy and the powerful
and then adjust the system for everybody
else
lastly beyond all of this just as a
final coda we haven't even gotten into
the litany of state-level charges that
state attorneys general are going to be
looking into we've heard that Maryland
and Washington DC are going to look into
emoluments violations by Trump at the
state level not pardonable new
defamation lawsuit against Trump is back
from summer servos that former
apprentice contestant that is now
happening New York state level
investigation into Trump using his
charity like a personal slush fund truly
stunning and the most stunning thing in
the end the most damaging thing in the
end in terms of what it says about the
American justice system will be if
Donald Trump is able to get out
unscathed and he may well and that would
be the real tragedy here we've been
throwing around the term emoluments for
a while now and let's reset that
conversation when we talk about the
emoluments clause in the Constitution
what we're talking about is article 1
section 9 Clause 8 of the Constitution
and what that does is make it illegal
for people in the federal government to
receive gifts and things of value from
foreign States and monarchies and the
argument is that Donald Trump is
violating the Constitution because he's
receiving a ton of things of value from
other countries including money when
foreign dignitaries pay to stay at his
hotel in Washington DC
omitting that it's to curry favor with
them and this is now going to be like
the tenth line of investigation against
Donald Trump this is separate from Trump
Russia this is separate from the
inauguration fraud that's being
investigated this is separate from
obstruction of justice
it's separate from the illegal hush
money payments it's a totally different
line of inquiry this is being
investigated at the state level which is
also important since state level
criminality cannot be pardoned away by
the presidential pardon power which is
of course federal what's going on is
that Attorney General's attorneys
general rather in Maryland and
Washington DC have so far sent 38
subpoenas to different parties related
to exploring if Donald Trump has
violated the Constitution's emoluments
clause Trump's Justice Department is now
panicking doing anything they can to
stop this from moving forward the Trump
Justice Department is saying this must
be stopped by a district court by the
January 3rd deadline for those 38
witnesses to respond to their subpoenas
Trump already tried getting this
dismissed at a lower court level lost
that appeal and when you look at the
legal brief Pat as to why they are
saying this needs to be stopped the
Justice Department is saying if you
don't stop these 38 witnesses from
responding to their subpoenas this could
be irreparably harmful to Donald Trump
think about that
why would merely knowing about his
finances be irreparably harmful Pat
unless he's done really sketchy things
and noticed how with all these scandals
the emoluments clause situation the hush
payments to mistresses that broke
campaign finance laws the Trump Russia
collusion angle we're no longer having a
conversation about if Trump did it if
Trump committed crimes it's really just
transitioning to what are we as a
country going to do about it that's
exactly right and what the conversation
now includes is the Justice Department
saying if you look at Trump's finances
this will cause irreparable damage to
him why would just looking at someone's
finances damage them unless there's
something really bad in there which
brings us back to the tax return
question if you intrusively looked at
the minutia of most people's finances
you wouldn't find irreparably harmful
evidence right if you intrusively looked
at my finances maybe you could say you
know David you said that you donated two
hundred and fifty dollars worth of
clothing to charity last year you really
should have valued that at 225 not 250
right that's not irreparably harmful in
any way if merely looking at someone's
finances would do them irreparable harm
that explains why you see these panicked
documents from the Justice Department
saying no no no you've got to stop this
right away we can't have Maryland and
Washington DC looking into whether
Donald Trump has violated the emoluments
clause which he pretty damn obviously
has what do you think would be exposed
if these 38 subpoenas are responded to
follow me on instagram and let me know
at David Pakman you can also follow the
show on instagram at david pakman show
let's talk about the economy and
specifically the stock market a little
bit the stock market decline is
continuing stocks yesterday closed at
their lowest level in 14 months
dating back to October 2017 is roughly
14 months and unless something
incredible happens in the last two weeks
of the year stocks are going to have
their worst year in 2018 in a decade
which happens to include eight years of
Barack Obama's presidency and two years
of Donald Trump's we talked last week
about how Donald Trump according to one
report is starting to panic about
whether his trade policy and his
presidency effectively his actions as
president are starting to make the
market erratic and contributing to the
stock market decline and yesterday I
jokingly satirically tweeted blaming
Barack Obama for this
it triggered way more of a reaction than
I anticipated I tweeted again jokingly
quote I can't believe Obama planted time
bombs in the economy so that the stock
market would start crashing now and give
us the worst year in a decade
just to make Donald Trump look bad now
most people understood that that was a
satirical tweet but shockingly many
didn't some people wrote to me angrily
simply denying the reality saying David
stocks are doing great under Donald
Trump they're not down for the year
under Trump they're up for the year I
don't even know how to respond to that I
mean if you can't just go to Google
Finance or Yahoo Finance and look at the
numbers or if you do when you don't
believe them I don't know what I can
tell you right I don't know sort of like
with with climate science if you're just
going to say the evidence is not the
evidence good luck I'm not going to be
able to really have a conversation with
you
other people warned me that it's risky
for me to tweet that satirical statement
because many of trumps followers will
see it and they'll believe it and
they'll start actually repeating this
absurdly ridiculous idea it is
interesting that Trump is now taking
another approach on Twitter which is
obviously never to mention that the
stock market is falling more and more he
never talks about that but if the stock
market is up you can be sure Pat that
he's going to be tweeting about it but
instead to tweet about how bad things
are elsewhere here's a very strange
tweet from Donald Trump as all of this
chaos is going down Trump tweets it is
incredible that with a very strong
dollar and virtually no inflation the
outside world is blowing up around us
Paris is burning and China way down the
Fed is even considering yet another
interest rate hike take the victory what
victory is Trump talking about here Pat
I don't even know what he's saying but
he seems to be pointing out I guess that
things are even worse in other countries
I think it's a classic example of Trump
moving the goal posts and it really this
has to come down to him at the end
today if he's gonna take all the credit
for strong metrics in the economy he has
to take the blame for the poorer metrics
in the economy and things are starting
to go downhill a little bit when he
talked about the stock market when he
talked about rates of homelessness and
to some degree we were just kind of due
for this right because we're
experiencing the second longest period
of American prosperity in history could
have happened under Hillary Clinton -
but Trump should have prepared a little
bit more with his words
early on when the economy was doing
better well as we've said before when
you hang your hat on particular metrics
when those metrics no longer are
favorable to you you either are
self-defeating if you continue to hang
your hat on them or if you never mention
them again you start to be very
apparently hypocritical which of course
Donald Trump is and what he's doing here
is just trying to redirect and of course
much of what we're talking about with
stocks only has a tangential effect on
many participants in the economy the
stock market is down down down okay a
lot of people don't own stock or don't
own much stock but they're still
affected by stock market declines in
many ways which we've discussed before
but there are macro issues which simply
aren't being touched here they're not
being touched when we talk about the
stock market they're certainly not being
touched by Donald Trump income
inequality exploded wage stagnation
continues manufacturing used as a
political football manufacturing jobs
rather than working with the reality
that a ton of those jobs aren't
returning because they simply don't
exist anymore
health care causing people to declare
bankruptcy you could get sick at any
time and lose all of your money and
meanwhile Donald Trump is gutting
Obamacare making that problem even worth
so it's wrong to say that the stock
market only affects rich people even
though rich people disproportionately
own the stocks but it's also wrong to
say that the stock market is the only
thing that matters what's next depends
on who's making decisions Ron Paul says
that we could have a 50% downturn in
stocks which could cause a 1929 style
depression that's one extreme do we
trust Ron Paul I'm not sure judge for
yourself the market dogmatists who put
all full faith in the market say the
market will solve the problem of the
market decline the market will also
solve the problems caused by the markets
decline we know that doesn't work I mean
that that's already been proven not to
be true if the noose of criminality as I
like to say continues to tighten around
Donald Trump how will that political
instability impact the stock market
probably pretty significantly
the one statement I agree with the right
on on this entire issue is we need to
fix the underlying problems to stabilize
the market and the economy the problem
is we don't agree on what those issues
are it's not quote debt it's not
immigration it's not China to the degree
that some on the right claim that it's
China it's that we have an economy
that's built on infinite growth and that
doesn't work for most people
and the side effect of it is that it's
destroying our planet by being
indifferent to climate change and the
damage we're doing to the environment if
we can't even get on the same page as to
what the problem is there's almost no
chance of whatsoever that we're going to
be able to fix it send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show okay so
I think you're gonna find this
interesting
I was going to be on fox news over the
weekend I was on Fox News a few months
ago and I was invited back over the
weekend I was going to be on Saturday at
1:30 p.m. Eastern Time with Leland
Vitter's during their sort of afternoon
right wing news that they do on every
weekend I was going to be debating the
topic of the recent Obamacare decision
in Texas with a conservative radio host
named RJ I believe it's RJ Harris RJ
something but RJ Harris I think is his
name I was booked on Fox News that
morning they sent me an email a little
after 9:00 a.m. saying it the new ruling
on Obama care is the topic for your
panel let me know if you have any
questions they had some source links
everything was good
to go now I made a mistake I didn't ask
for a ride to the studio and the reason
I didn't is because when they send you a
ride they insist on bringing you there
so early that you just sit in a chair
with an earpiece for forty-five minutes
literally with nothing to do so I prefer
to get there 10 minutes before the
appearance so I got got myself my own
ride I show up there it's a satellite
facility meaning it's not owned by Fox
it's a company that just does satellite
space they have a chair you can sit in
and you can join up with CNN or Fox News
or whoever and I ring the doorbell and
instead of ringing inside I can tell
that it goes to like a central number
for the company that runs these studios
and I say it's David Pakman I'm here for
my Fox News appearance and there's a
sort of confused
pregnant pause and then they say Fox
told us that was cancelled I said how is
this possible it's just a couple hours
ago they confirmed the topic and and the
time they said we don't know it's just
but we don't work for Fox it's been
canceled so I ended up going back home
and ultimately getting a hold of the
producers and basically what they said
is oh it was canceled and what happened
is no one remembered to tell you like
yeah I know but I know that that's what
happened it was canceled and no one told
me that's the issue and there was no
further explanation given and they
offered to pay for my lift ride down
there it's not even worth the time the
time to submit for a reimbursement for
what the lift ride cost and people
started sending me every possible
explanation people saying David they
tricked you they wanted to waste your
time because you did so well on Fox News
last time and then not have you on they
don't have the time to do that as much
as you might attribute malice to this
it's just unprofessionalism that's all
it is it's not there's there's no one
there who says here's an idea in the
middle of booking an entire show let's
get David Pakman to just show up at a
studio and then there won't be any
segment like Pat this this is just
unprofessionalism and I'm proud to say
we've never done this to a guest ever if
we have to move something if something
gets postponed or has to be
we are 100% communicating with them
because we value and respect the time of
the guests sometimes more than they
respect ours and our experience by the
way but we would never do something this
unprofessional absolutely true and I
remember when you went on Fox News back
in July we expected them to set you up
but to do so by the way that they frame
their questions and try to like get you
into traps and have this really weird
setup so you wouldn't sound all that
coherent and articulate this time they
set you up to fail in a totally
different way which is the no call no
show and I think this time they actually
succeeded in doing that they did and I
take these appearances seriously I spent
a couple hours in the morning
researching the topic making sure that I
was going to be ready because I know
that even though they say listen they
say I'm gonna be debating a right-wing
radio host RJ Harris or whatever but I
know I'm really gonna be debating the
Fox News anchor and the right-wing guy I
know they're gonna tag-team me I know
I'm gonna show up and the Lighting's
gonna look ridiculous and I'm gonna look
like a vampire compared to everybody
else which is what happened last time I
was there I know that they will lower my
microphone when I start to get
argumentative and go back and forth I'm
okay with that because I still think
it's worth trying to break their echo
chamber and bust their safe space I'm
okay with that but just let me know if
you've cancelled it and definitely next
time if there is a next time although
there may not be the way things are
going I will just say listen based on
what happened last time you got to send
me a ride I'm not I'm not gonna get
there on my own and that way at least if
the ride doesn't show up it would be a
hint that maybe this segment has been
cancelled so I know a lot of people were
looking forward to the appearance I had
promoted it to some degree and I think
it would have been absolutely great
particularly because right-wingers were
making such a big deal out of this
Obamacare decision which is immediately
on hold like literally a decision was
made by a Texas judge it's immediately
on hold and you can keep signing up for
Obamacare and nothing is changing and
the immediate and I was going to make
that point and tell them that they are
fomenting a false narrative and point
out that the article that they published
about it ignores the fact that nothing
is changing right now but it didn't
happen it didn't happen and that's
that's a shame would have been a great
great appearance let's follow up about a
Jordan Peterson I have a
hilarious update to last week's jordan
Peterson's story and I know I'm doing
something that a lot of people in the
audience don't like it when I do which
is I'm talking about Jordan Peterson two
weeks in a row but I have to because I
have to update you about the obvious
hypocrisy that I pointed out last week
to catch you up we did a segment last
week where the segment was called Jordan
Peterson caught saying truly stupid
things and in that segment I explained
that Jordan Peterson had tweeted about
how when you call someone a climate
science denier you're trying to smear
them by making them equivalent to a
Holocaust denier okay just as a reminder
the tweet that Jordan Peterson sent out
and I mentioned this last week says he's
casually about Bjorn Lomborg he's
casually called the climate change
denier for example which is an
appallingly treacherous term of
criticism used to denigrate someone
personally by associating them with
Holocaust deniers the ethics of anyone
who employs it should be instantly
questioned now as I pointed out last
week this is a really dumb argument it
makes no sense saying that someone
denies climate science or they deny
reality or they deny the results of
yesterday's Boston Celtics game saying
someone as a denier is not an ad hominem
meant to associate them with Holocaust
denial I mean it's just stupid right
don't need to rehash that but then we
also found out that not only is Jordan
Peterson wrong he's a total hypocrite on
this issue previously calling other
people deniers
one such tweet that I showed you last
week says University of Toronto
professor a biological sex denier on
Canadian public television with me so
that's where we got to last week here's
where it gets even better
Jordan Peterson actually way more
directly slammed the use of the word
denier in a tweet again last week the
day after our segment and by then our
clip and others informed people that
he has used the exact same term about
others in the past he'd ended up
deleting that tweet after being
absolutely crushed for the double
standard hypocrisy but thanks to the
magic of the internet we have the tweet
Jordan Peterson posted all those who or
let me see where I can find it here here
is all those who dare use the phrase
denier associating their critics with
those who questioned the existence of
the Holocaust immediately identify
themselves as incapable of civilized
discourse so many people called him out
for the fact that he has called people
deniers multiple times in the past that
he ended up having to pull that one down
why is he shy away from the controversy
Pat you would think that he would want
to explore this Marxist postmodernist
attack on young men everywhere wouldn't
he I was actually gonna call you a
Jordan Peterson intelligence than Dyer
but I don't want to be grouped into the
same pool of people who deny the
Holocaust so I'm going to refrain from
doing that it's not going super well and
I think this is advice from the
intellectual dark web that we here don't
make umbrella critiques okay the
intellectual dark web likes to say that
make specific criticisms don't write off
a system as patriarchal explain which
elements specifically are patriarchal
and let's talk about them and if we
agree we can fix them right we always
hear about that from the intellectual
dark web well why then say that anyone
who uses the term denier is trying to
smear people as being similar to or
associated with Holocaust denial explain
why climate science is wrong if you can
I would argue that you can't because the
science is not on your side and then we
can explore that
so not a particularly good seven to ten
days for Jordan Peterson I will be
interested in seeing whether
continues covering his tracks by
deleting further tweets